hey everyone so last week Amazon just
announced a hiring freeze a note was
sent out to Amazon employees explained
the situation and there's been a lot of
speculation around potential layoffs I
worked at Amazon for two and a half
years and naturally as someone who makes
videos all about helping people get into
AWS and land a job in the cloud I've
received a lot of messages from job
Seekers asking me Lucy what is going on
do I still have a chance of Landing a
job at AWS now I'm not going to
sugarcoat it and say things will all be
okay and that it won't be harder for you
to get into AWS the whole economy is at
a pretty uncertain place right now and
we've all seen recent articles like
Twitter slashes nearly half of its
Workforce and that's a lays off 11 000
staff these types of headlines have been
in the news for a few months now and
whilst it started off with smaller
companies and early stage startups the
big Tech giants like Amazon Google Apple
and meta are now feeling the effects and
honestly it's pretty heartbreaking to
see because layoffs mean that people are
forced to find new jobs with very very
short notice and with home freezes going
on there are now Less open positions
available for people searching for jobs
what's worse is that these are more than
just shocking numbers and big headlines
behind every layoff and hiring freeze
there are real people and lives being
impacted in this video I'll be
explaining what exactly is happening
with Amazon's hiring freeze and my
advice on how to adjust your job seeking
strategy so that you can build the
relevant skills to maximize your chances
of Landing a job in Tech and just as a
disclaimer all opinions presented here
are my own many of you have reached out
to me feeling stressed about the hiring
freeze so I don't want to spread any
fear and negativity in this video
instead I want to provide you with some
actionable steps that you can take to
make the most of this tough situation so
here's a summary of what's going on with
Amazon's hiring freeze the company
decided to pause on new incremental
hires in the corporate Workforce this
freeze will be in place for the next few
months Amazon will continue to monitor
what they're seeing with the economy and
the business and adjust in a way that
they think makes sense if people leave
the company or move on to other roles
there were higher back views to replace
them on a brighter note Amazon mentions
that they still intend to hire a
meaningful number of people in 2023 and
they remain excited about significant
investments in their larger businesses
and newer initiatives like Amazon Prime
video Alexa Grocery and so on they
didn't mention AWS specifically but I'm
guessing that fits into their larger
businesses since their Amazon web
services business is a major source of
profit from the perspective of someone
who has spent the past two and a half
years working at AWS I can kind of see
why they decided to announce a hiring
freeze and it's probably the same reason
why Google and apple chose to do the
same one reason obviously is to lower
costs but I believe another reason is to
protect internal employees by reacting
early and recognizing that hiring needs
to slow down they can try and prevent
situations where they have to lay off
people already working in the company I
know for some of you that sounds like a
pretty obvious statement for me to make
but I wanted to emphasize that instead
of focusing on energy on blaming the
companies or all we can do at this point
is to try and make the most of the
situation
okay so at this point it's kind of hard
to tell what roles at AWS and Amazon
will remain open that's just the reality
of things right now but my advice is
that if you're currently in the
interview process definitely double
check with the recruiter or your main
point of contact and ask if they have
more information I'd recommend also
browsing a nap could blind it's an
anonymous forum and Community for
employees to discuss different topics
including the Amazon hiring freeze and
for those who aren't in the interview
process I'd highly recommend revisiting
your job search strategy so instead of
just looking for roles in one or two of
your dream companies maybe diversify a
bit and explore positions in other
companies for example Amazon has a
Global Network of Partners and these
partners are also looking for people
with Cloud skills another tip is to
spend time updating your resume building
relevant skills and practicing interview
questions essentially making sure you're
well prepared so that if a great
opportunity does come up you'll be able
to apply right away I'd recommend taking
a look at the job descriptions of the
roles you're interested in to figure out
what skills they look for I have a bunch
of videos on AWS certifications Cloud
projects and what it's like working at
AWS if you'd like to stay updated feel
free to subscribe to the channel because
I'll be uploading new videos every week
so speaking of building relevant skills
I like to take a moment to introduce
today's video response to skillshare
first of all let me just say skillshare
is offering a one month free trial and I
personally love some of the courses I've
been taking it's an online learning
community with thousands of classes for
anyone who loves learning and wants to
explore their creativity and learn new
skills if you have specific skills
you're trying to learn skillshare is a
great place to start from ticket Finance
to productivity graphic design and more
you can find classes that will match
your goals and interests here is the
course by hashtag learning providing an
absolute beginner's introduction to
Amazon web services they also have a
bunch of other Cloud courses so if
you're on your Cloud Learning Journey
I'd recommend checking out skillshare
the first 1000 people to use the link in
the video description below will get a
free one month trial of skillshare so
thank you skillshare for sponsoring
today today's video the final tip is to
show your work I read this book and it
completely changed the way I've used
self-promotion and posting on LinkedIn
so most people once they learn something
new or build something cool they kind of
just keep it to themselves and don't
share it with the world but as a job
Seeker showcasing your skills and
projects will help you build up a
network of people who want you to
succeed for example let's say you build
a cloud project maybe an Amazon next
chatbot you can make a LinkedIn post
explaining how you built it and what
skills you developed when other people
see your post and find it helpful or
interesting they may reach out to you
and slowly start building a network
these people in your network might then
connect you with recruiters jobs and
opportunities that will help you in your
search alright so that's all I have to
say about Amazon's hiring freeze and how
you can make the most of the situation
please give this video a like if you got
something out of it and I'll see you
soon bye for now